let's talk about genetically modified
foods something we haven't talked about
in a little while so we have this year's
Nobel Prize winners for chemistry they
are saying that the fears about
genetically modified foods are overblown
and that society stands to benefit from
the genetic modification of food so what
I want to do here is really go back to
the beginning and kind of reset our
discussion about GMO foods since it's
been a while since I've talked about it
there are some people in our audience
who disagree with me about vaccines
there are some people in the audience
who disagree with me about genetically
modified foods so to restate my view on
genetically modified foods my view is
that based on the science I've read
there is no evidence that genetically
modified foods are unhealthy for humans
on the basis of being genetically
modified so let's parse that and make
sure that I have clarity this evening if
a food is genetically modified and
treated with toxic pesticides it could
be bad for human health because of the
pesticides that are toxic not because of
the genetic modification there is not
evidence I've seen and I've looked for
it that genetic modifications are bad
for human health let's go through some
of the typical rebuttal attempts and
deal with them one by one the most
common rebuttal attempt is David what
about that study with the rats and what
people are referring to when they
mention the study with the rats is the
seralini GMO rat tumor study so let's
talk about that study that study has
been debunked by scientists three
specific studies have completely
debunked the seralini GMO rat tumor
study and in fact that study has been
retracted unfortunately you may not have
heard of that because GMO opponents
continue to cite that study continue to
tout that study as evidence that GMOs
are not healthy on the basis merely that
they are genetically modified some of
the problems with the seralini GMO rat
tumor study include that they used a
strain of rats known to have really high
rates of tumors making it the exact
wrong type of rat that you would
to use for the test they had a very
small sample size and a number of
conflicts of interest were uncovered in
terms of the participants the immediate
and sort of more ancillary participants
to that study so that study is out and
there have been many studies which find
no dangers from GMOs which gets me to
the next typical anti GMO talking point
which is hey David listen it's possible
that GMOs aren't damaging to human
health but we just don't know if GMOs
are unhealthy for humans because we
don't have any long-term testing and
GMOs are so new and of course that's
wrong GMOs have been studied extensively
they first appeared in labs 30 years ago
they've been sold commercially since
1994 there are 1700 peer-reviewed safety
studies about GMOs period now to be
clear I have no horse in this I know
people will say either because of Soros
or because I'm Jewish or because I'm a
shill or because I'm in the pocket of
the big food industry or whatever listen
I have no horse in this you can be damn
sure that if I thought science supported
GMOs being unhealthy I would be leading
the charge against GMOs however that's
not where the evidence is pointing 141
Nobel laureates support GMO food and
have signed on to a document making that
clear the attempt to discredit those 141
Nobel laureates is literally out of the
climate denier handbook the skeptics or
the anti GMO people are saying okay fine
listen these are Nobel laureates but
their work isn't directly related to
GMOs so what the hell do they know which
is the same thing we hear from the write
about climate science they say a lot of
those so-called scientists don't
actually work in climatology even if
they work in related fields but when you
look at the list of the hundred and
forty-one Nobel laureates who say were
in favor of GMO food they work in
chemistry they work in medicine which
are very related to GMOs others
admittedly work in physics and economics
those are less
related to GMOs but the point is the
consensus from people working in a
variety of fields on this is that there
is not evidence that GMOs are harmful to
human health on the basis of being
genetically modified sadly lots of the
same people who fall for the anti GMO
stuff are the same people who fall for
things labeled all-natural
or derived from natural ingredients on
food products and unfortunately there's
also crossover between the anti-vaxxers
and the anti GMO people so you know I
think my main point here Pat is to just
point out that number one the idea that
I would have any interest in hiding that
GMOs are bad for people if that's what I
believe is crazy I mean there's no
sensible way that someone could make
that argument this program is not the
type of thing big pharma big agriculture
would even be interested in funding and
that's absolutely and totally silly but
most importantly there are people who on
most issues follow the science and then
on one issue sometimes it's vaccinations
sometimes it's GMO sometimes it's Russia
gate whatever they seem to be
disconnected from the facts on one
particular issue like it's their blind
spot in a sense right it's poor critical
thinking and I'm not a scientist so my
approach to it is to just trust the
overwhelming scientific majority's
opinion and that's what I do when it
comes to climate change and that's what
I do with GMOs I guess you know another
concern is labeling foods that are using
GMOs and I think that's something I can
get behind just from a consumers rights
perspective I think if people don't want
to consume GMOs they should be allowed
to make that choice and they should know
what they're putting into their bodies
well that's sort of a separate issue
it's a separate issue and I agree with
you that I'm totally fine with that
labeling I think in 15 years that labor
labeling will be silly and redundant
because basically everything will be
genetically modified to some degree so
I'm totally fine with that I have zero
opposition to that I think it's fine I
think in 15 years it's going to be seen
as a completely irrelevant thing and
sort of along those lines
there are other issues with GMOs that
are ancillary issues like for example
patented seeds which can be modified to
not produce more seeds or to concentrate
the ability to grow food by large
corporations those are things related to
GMO which are problems but they don't go
to the health of the GMOs so let's
criticize that using pesticides
alongside GMO food I don't like that
that's a problem we've got to critically
analyze each pesticide to see if it's
harmful to human health but that's
separate than the health of the food on
the basis of being genetically modified
there's another issue when we look at
crops which might be genetically
modified or not that are damaging to the
environment look at soybeans for example
soybeans require lime and synthetic
fertilizer to grow in large quantities
growing soybeans damages soil in ways
that other crops don't don't it can hurt
biodiversity it can contribute the soul
soil erosion those are issues with
soybeans whether or not they've been
genetically modified and totally
separate from the human health effects
of that genetic modification anyway
these are some examples but GMO by
virtue merely of being GMO shouldn't be
targeted by activists until we have
actual evidence that it's bad for us and
right now we simply don't have good
evidence that that's the case we have a
great program for you today I will be
taking calls I will be answering
questions we are going to so Monday I am
scheduled to have jury duty and I'm
going to find out later today whether I
have to report or not I'm hoping that I
don't and that I can be here hosting the
show on Monday if not we have gotten a
tentative agreement from Ferran cousins
of Ring of Fire he is going to be
standing by for the call from the court
if I have to be in court on Monday
Ferran cousins will be here on Monday
guest hosting the show but in any case
then the rest of the week unless I get
pulled into
big trial I will be here great program
today great bonus show thanks for being
with us one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an amazing online
learning community that offers thousands
of high quality classes on almost any
topic first 500 people who click the
link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class offered by Skillshare
they've got classes on everything from
design video editing photography
business technology cooking meditation
even classes on personal productivity I
know you'll be able to find something on
Skillshare that fascinates you or even
something that will help you in your
everyday life classes are taught by real
people who care about what they're
teaching I just took a really great
class on more advanced video editing
techniques the david pakman show is
giving you two months of free access to
every class they offer when you click
the link under this video
think about everything you'll have at
your fingertips for two whole months
totally free hard to beat and after that
if you like it you can keep access to
every class on Skillshare for under ten
bucks a month one of the most affordable
learning platforms out there just click
the link under this video to redeem your
to three months of skill share but hurry
it's only available to the first 500 who
sign up